our guy in the know in the nba rick
beuker fox sports nba analyst
welcome to the show rick thanks for
having me fellas
love the uh the conversation about uh
building our kids into uh stars that we
can just sit back and
and uh ride there that's the dream
hey all right ride the flow yeah my son
my son
is going to be either six eight or six
nine
um so i'm gonna probably need some
guidance from you on where i need to go
in terms of coaching
and uh especially where he needs to
probably go to high school that's that's
probably a big
big one of these we'll uh we'll take
care of that although high school is
is very over hyped now uh it's the aau
program that you go to okay is going to
be the
deciding factor but uh certainly we can
we can get into that
i'm i'm here for you well heads up heads
up for the name macgyver leaf
six foot eight two hundred and you know
thirty five pounds that uh
you know i don't know i don't know that
that really sticks in the memory
and that's pretty ordinary john smith
joe jones and macgyver lee
did not like the others yeah nick g
mcgee um
trade deadline coming up thursday um
couple big names
you know how interesting would it be if
lonzo ball is again somewhere else it
just seems like he's been passed around
we heard magic johnson talk about him
having one of the highest point guard
iqs he can think of
uh what happens there
i really okay so don't ask me to dive
into magic's comments about lonzo paul
with that that will
that could hijack the show i could spend
a lot of time on that but um
what i find interesting is there are a
number of really quality point guards
out there lonzo ball being one kyle
lowry being another
supposedly malcolm brogdon with the
indiana pacers
uh there there are some game-changing
point guards that are on the market and
there are a couple of teams notably the
los angeles clippers
that could certainly uh use one i would
love to see
lonzo go back to la go to the clippers
see him paired up with paul george and
kawhi leonard from a defensive
standpoint that would just be
a nightmare for opposing teams and they
could really use a
a pass first uh point guard and
and certainly lonzo is that he's also
done a remarkable job
of improving his his three-point
shooting which is
going to space the floor for times when
you want to put the ball in paul
george or kawhi leonard's hand so i i
would i would love to see him
play on a meaningful team because i
think he just got
unfairly hammered through no fault of
his own because
it didn't work out with the lakers he
didn't he didn't
propose that he was one of the best
point guards or was going to become a
lakers legend or any of that stuff his
dad did and magic did and
magic appears to be continuing to just
put the bar
so high that people are going to look at
lonzo and suggest that he
is underperforming and i i i look i
i appreciate any guy who comes in the
league brian
you know this that that um you get to
the pros
but now it's a matter of it doesn't
matter where you were drafted you got to
prove you could play yeah
and uh and it's not your fault where you
get drafted
you know somebody decided you were worth
this so it's on them
as much as you to develop you to be that
and uh you know the lakers pulled the
rip cord on that
and lonzo has gone about just making
himself in the best player he can be
he has clearly made strides he's clearly
worked on his weaknesses
and so i i for the kid's sake i would
love to see him go someplace where he's
meaningful but
um you know as far as guys who would
change the dynamic
kyle lowry potentially going to the
miami heat and
wherever malcolm brogdon would go i'm
really surprised by the pacers
wanting to move him because for what the
pacers are
malcolm brogdon has been in my mind
their mvp
i think he may not be worth the contract
that he has
but uh if if the pacers move him
then that changes the dynamic of their
team going forward in a in a big way i
think malcolm
is a very underrated uh point guard in
this league as much as
magic might suggest that lonzo ball is
rick
rick bucher joining us fox sports nba
analyst
um also uh
you know lonzo is leading his best year
in
scoring three-pointers and field goal
percentage so i mean he's
he's gradually improving every time he
steps for a guy that doesn't
follow the nba as closely as you do or
or
or the experts i we continue to see
and hear about if if lebron and a.d
uh are are healthy the lakers and the
nets are on a collision course but
with this injury to lebron and the
absence of a.d
moving forward are they unless they add
a piece where they can help them win the
pelicans beat them last night
are we yeah you know what what's the
fight is it as long as they get in as an
eight seed
you know it's all that matters of the
houston rockets from the from the mid
90s as long as they get in and they're
going to win a championship is that
a good where are we at with that yeah
look it's uh it's a fair question first
of all we don't know
what a.d you know where a.d and lebron
are going to be
when they get back i've been under
uh underwhelmed by the
uh the impact of the players that the
lakers added
last summer marc gasol was supposed to
be
a a play-making big that
was going to outperform
dwight howard that has not happened wes
matthews was supposed to be an upgrade
from danny green
that has not happened mantras harold was
supposed to be
you know that energizer off the bench
that he was for the clippers in the
regular season last year
that has not happened he hasn't played
to the same level dennis shooter is
really the only addition
that has definitely been a plus and so
um i i don't you know where where they
are cap wise
what they have uh to to trade i
i can't see them adding a significant
piece
and their best asset is the fact that
they do have a core
kuz and a.d and kentavious caldwell pope
and lebron obviously a crew
that has alex caruso has
has won a championship knows what it
takes to win a championship
has the confidence that winning a
championship breeds
and so i to me it's you know don't
maintain as much continuity as you can
from last year
hope you can be healthy at the right
time the scariest part is
uh i i mean i can see them sinking all
the way down to the
you know the seventh eighth ninth spot
and
if that's the case then it's suddenly
the ncaa tournament for them
it's one game you know if they if they
get to the eighth spot
or the seventh spot when the when the
playoffs start
okay then i you know there's not a real
home court advantage without fans and
they've seen everything and done
everything so i i think their chances
are just as good
assuming they're healthy but i you know
how many upsets have we seen in the ncaa
tournament
on one given night if you don't have it
uh you're suddenly out and that's the
prospect
that the lakers could suddenly face is
you know they they face a hungry dallas
mavericks team or
portland trailblazers or who you know
name golden state warriors it gets into
a game where it's possession by
possession at the end and
uh one missed shot on their part and
one made shot by the opposition and
suddenly
they're not in the playoffs that is the
scariest part of where they are
is that um i don't think they can hold a
seed where they are guaranteed
to be in the playoffs they very well may
be in a in a play-in game and that's a
one game you know decides it all and
that would be a scary proposition
wow that's uh laker fans you're out
there
kyle kuzma is the hero you need i guess
right now um
what about uh let's let's talk a couple
of other names uh before we get you out
of here uh we're speaking with rick
beuker fox sports nba
analyst uh andre drummond the buyout
market there
and and and aaron gordon you know aaron
gordon seems to be a guy that we always
talk about as a great player but
seemingly kind of been been in the
background so andre
drummond and aaron gordon there yeah you
know the difficulty with those two guys
is that they for the most part have been
uh main cogs
with their teams and whoever they would
go to if they're going to go to a
meaningful team
they're not going to be a maine cog guy
they're going to be a guy who
potentially comes off the bench and has
to be a role player
and that is such a different role it's
one thing when you're
the main player and you get all the
touches you get all the minutes
your efficiency you don't have to worry
if you if you start out
one for five one for six like i i'm
gonna play another 30 minutes i'm going
to get another 15 shots
i'm i can find my way back into this
game
uh for where they are uh they are now
and the potential of who they would join
they're now coming in
and they got to give you you know four
explosive minutes
and and really have an impact on the
game are they capable
of doing that both not just physically
skill wise but
mentally are they willing to accept that
and i think it's why
like aaron gordon has been has wanted
out of orlando
since the end of last season if not
last summer uh i i i was hearing that he
was looking to go elsewhere
and uh and yet the market you know
isn't there because they have proved
themselves to at this point
to be really good players to be quasi
stars on mediocre teams and
the weight of that lands on if this is
my
best player and we're only a mediocre
team
then maybe he's a mediocre star and the
question is going to be can they accept
being a role player can they accept
being a complimentary player
on a great team and then can they accept
it mentally and then are they capable of
pulling it off physically
and that's where that's where they are
and that's why you haven't seen
i mean andre german's been on the market
since the beginning of the year
um you know nobody's jumping to to get
andre drummond because
um you know nobody's looking to rebuild
around drama they've seen teams that are
built around him
and you know they didn't get very far so
uh
and i just on the buyout market like i
think
maybe blake griffin if he's healthy can
do some things for the brooklyn nets
but lamarcus aldridge andre drummond
aaron gordon
i they're they're interesting names but
i don't really see them
moving the needle i would think that
alonzo ball or
kyle lowry or a malcolm brogdon would
have
far more of an impact depending on where
they go all right we're
talking to rick bucher uh you can check
him out on
the ball podcast with rick buker fox
sports nba analyst before i get you out
here just quick answer to this
uh i don't need as opposed to the long
ones i gave you
no i love that i love that we're
it's a simple question is the golden
state warriors
run over yes
there we go i like it because that's
what i told everybody the other day
i am not an nba analyst or a expert and
i told everybody guys
the window is closing the window has
closed yeah yeah all right no no the win
yeah the window is closed yeah
it's uh i mean you look at the age you
look at the the the
tread on the tires and you look at what
made them special and unique
and um none of those things are there
well rick
thank you for taking the time rick
bucher fox sports nba analyst check him
out on the ball podcast with rick bucher
thanks for taking some time today rick
my pleasure
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here